what's the best way to go about meeting
a girl for a long-term relationship i
can go about it online or i can do it in
person and i feel like there's pros and
cons to both but i want to hear your
opinion on it the best roi is online
generally if you have a proper online
dating profile with good photography
you're good at getting the number and
setting up the date and you've got game
it's very easy to have options now i
would say don't just do that as you go
about your day and you come across an
attractive woman that you dig just walk
up to her make a cold approach see if
you can open and get her number and get
a date okay cool so if i'm setting up my
online profile what would you recommend
in terms of trying to get pictures
things like that professional
photography you need the mystery shot
you need the group a friend shot you
need a good um like head shot like a
good smile you need one showing off you
know your physique those would be the
main ones right she has to basically
look at it and go oh yeah i want to be
in that picture with that guy with those
people in that environment she's going
to be doing this and she's going to be
like oh there's buzz lightyear i'm going
to swipe right on that guy